[Intro music]
Defense mechanism are the brain's ways
of keeping us safe from fully aware
of unpleasant thoughts and feelings.
Sometimes, we can choose to use certain
defense mechanisms
like repression, denial and rationalization.
Below is a list of ten of the most common
defense mechanisms.
1. Displacement.
The diversion of emotions such as anger,
from the original source to a substitute target.
For example,
Your friend says something hurtful
and instead of confronting your friend,
you later lash out at your sister.
2. Projection.
The projection of one's own feelings,
thoughts or motives onto someone else.
For example,
the person who is cheating
is under the impression that their
partner is cheating on them.
3. Rationalization.
Developing false though plausible excuses
to justify irrational and/or
unacceptable behaviour.
For example,
Stealing from a corporate chain store
such as Best Buy
and justifying the theft by saying:
"They make millions in profit
so it doesn't matter"
4. Reaction Formation.
Behaving in a way opposite
to how you feel.
For example,
When a person is romantically
attracted to someone,
but adamantly claims that
they dislike that someone.
5. Regression.
Reverting to childlike patterns of behavior.
For example,
A student gets a bad grade on their test
and screams and cries at
their parents or teacher.
6. Repression/ Denial.
Pushing or burying thoughts and feelings
that are distressing into the subconcious.
For example,
An addict will deny they have an addiction
because they can function fine
at work and at home.
An example of repression
would be a person
who witnessed a crime being
unable to remember the event.
7. Sublimation.
The refocusing of unacceptable
impulses, thoughts and raw emotions
into more acceptable ones.
For example,
A person who is experiencing
aggressive impulses
instead challenges that energy
into rigorous exercise.
8. Dissociation.
The detachment from the reality
and from oneself
and the finding of another
representation of self
to cope up with extreme stress or conflict.
A person uses dissociation
as a defense mechanism
disconnects from the reality
and lives in their own world,
in which they do not experience
unbearable thoughts, feelings or memories
for a period of time.
9. Intellectualization.
Overthinking and misdirection of focus
when confronted with unacceptable
situations, behaviors or impulses.
For example,
A person who has been told
the close family member has died,
begins to focus on
and overthinks the details
of planning a funeral, etc,
instead of expressing their grief.
10. Compensation.
The counterbalancing of perceived
flaws or weaknesses
by instead emphasizing strengths.
For example,
A person says they can't draw
but they're really good at dancing.
What defense mechanism do you use?
Share your thoughts with us below!
Also, don't forget to subscribe
and check out our Patreon!
Thanks for watching!
Hey everybody, I just wanna give
a personal thank you video
for you guys for always supporting Psych2go
and making it all possible for us.
Our vision is to make
psychology as accessible as possible
so that it promotes self-awareness
and it helps you guys grow.
However, we want to make more content for you guys
and would love your support
and buy one of these bracelets
from my partner introvert Pallas
Check out the bracelet,
it's pretty cool
and it even includes Pluto!
The link to purchase will be all
in the description below
and I hope you guys have an amazing day!
Bye!